c'est l'image qui symbolisera sa
première semaine au pouvoir joe biden
kissing qui rossing et qu'ils signent
encore des décrets présidentiels à tour
de bras
le 46e président américain veut montrer
que ces 78 printemps de l'onp a ramolli
et ses premiers jours à la maison
blanche sont riches en enseignements
mais attention vous allez voir que la
gestion du quatre hommes va lui offrir
un immense défi dès les premiers mois de
son mandat
si l'on en croit foxnews et son
présentateur vedette sean hannity la
première semaine de joe biden à
washington a été désastreuse
seulement le diagnostic a été livrée dès
le 21 janvier soit grosso modo après une
journée de travail de joe biden c'est un
détail mais qui veut dire beaucoup on y
reviendra
revenons au signature de joe biden et à
ces décrets we need ce qu'il faut déjà
noter c'est qu'on a un nombre très
important d'ordres exécutif en trois
jours il en avait déjà signé 29 ordre
exécutif pour comparer avec ce qui avait
fait barack obama c'était 5 en trois
jours et donald trump c'était un seul en
trois jours donc c'est vraiment c'est
pas de jaux l'endormir comme le la plage
de ball-trap on terminait d'une crise
très grave donc il pouvait pas se
permettre d'avoir l'air
hésitant dans ses premières décisions
politiques certains décrets concernent
la réponse à la crise pandémique par
exemple l'obligation pour tous les
agents fédéraux de porter le masque
idem pour tous les américains dans les
aéroports sur le discours aussi le
changement est très nette avec son
prédécesseur
on avait un président trump qui depuis
le début de la crise a cherché à
minimiser cette crise pandémique qui a
déjà fait plus de morts que la seconde
guerre mondiale aux états unis donc
c'est considérable plus de 410 morts et
joe biden arrivé en fonction s'inscrit
absolument porte à faux à cette attitude
conséquences qui a amusé beaucoup les
médias le sourire retrouvé du docteur
fochi qui coordonne la réponse sanitaire
depuis le début et qui était
régulièrement rabrouer par donald trump
dans ces âmes sensibles s'abstenir parce
que je suis fier du cynisme politique
c'est malvenu quatre cent mille morts
les etats unis 4 % de la population
mondiale 20% des bords de la planète
celle allié politique de joe biden il a
intérêt à ces mines et politiquement
c'est à dire que il a à la fois un cénac
et dit viser vraiment à 50 50
il a eu une aile gauche de son parti
lakovic 19
c'est une manière de dire c'est la
priorité que vous soyez de doha gauche
j'allais dire en poussant à l'extrême
que vous soyez un suprémaciste blanc ou
un militant des black light ce matin
vous voulez pas mourir
lakovic 19 de nombreux décrets
reviennent aussi sur des décisions
prises par trump
au menu le retour des etats-unis dans la
corde paris ou dans l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
l'arrêt de la construction du mur à la
frontière avec le mexique
ou plus exactement l'arrêt de son
financement l'abrogation du décret
interdisant l'accès au territoire
américain pour certains pays musulmans
en somme il
des textes qui reviennent sur des choses
qui avait heurté les démocrates au cours
de la précédente mandature et des textes
qui signe le retour de l'amérique dans
le grand concert des nations en misant
sur le multilatéralisme c'est à dire la
conviction qu'il faut être plusieurs
pour adresser les grands défis
internationaux
parallèlement la nouvelle administration
met sur la table un gigantesque plan de
relance à plus de 1900 milliards de
dollars surnommé l' american risq ue
plein alors qu'un plan de 900 milliards
venait déjà d'être validée en décembre
dernier il démocrates considèrent que le
dernier plan de relance qui a été votée
en décembre ne suffit pas parce qu'en
fait il ne met pas assez d'argent dans
les poches qui étaient américains
si l'on résume l'aide se décline en
trois volets 1000 milliards pour des
aides financières directes aux
américains dont un chèque de 1400
dollars dans leurs poches 440 milliards
pour soutenir les entreprises 415
milliards aussi pour combattre la
pandémie et intensifier la vaccination
tous là on parle il ya une réunion de
sénateur à la maison blanche
by partisans qui demandent à ce que
compartimente un peu parce que la job
indienne est en train de faire un petit
peu le coup du package aux sénateurs et
puis du côté des républicains il ya
comment on va essayer de diviser un
petit peu ce plan c'est agbank qui est
fait pour voter des parties peuvent pas
forcément là dessus le congrès se
prononcera d'abord la chambre des
représentants acquises aux démocrates
puis le sénat a également acquis aux
démocrates de justesse après l'élection
sénatoriale de géorgie star rapport de
force important pour joe biden s'il veut
entreprendre de grandes réformes
notamment sur la question raciale
l'éducation ou la réforme de santé et
enfin le défi de long terme pour joe
biden résumer en un mort est liée au
léger une promesse d'apaisement
difficile à tenir à cause du calendrier
politique car le 8 février va commencer
au sénat le procès olympique chemin de
donald trump
l'enjeu n'est pas de faire partir
l'ancien président c'est chose faite
mais de le rendre inéligible
pour le prochain mandat il ya une
question difficile à résoudre c'est de
savoir
faut-il privilégier la réconciliation au
risque d'avoir un sentiment d'impunité
pour tous ces leaders politiques
donald trump mais aussi tous les gens
qui l'ont suivi qui ont vendu un
mensonge au peuple américain depuis
trois mois c'est pas seulement les
mensonges de donald important qu'il
était en poste c'est le mensonge qu'il
aurait gagné l'élection de novembre 2020
et que à ce titre joe biden soit
illégitime
comment est-ce qu'on se réconcilie
comment est ce qu'on dit aux américains
allez passons à autre chose travaillons
ensemble dans l'unité face à cette crise
endémique
quand dans le même temps se déchirent
politique nous avons entendu françois
durpaire le dire le terrain politique de
joe biden est miné à sa gauche une
minorité progressiste qui attend des
réformes aussi impatiemment que bernie
sanders attend l'hiver à sa droite 70
millions d'électeurs de trump à qui il
veut tendre la main et c'est là que l'on
revient à sean hannity fox news et son
audience en fait que donald trump soient
rendus inéligibles ou non ce procès en
english man va occuper tout l'espace
médiatique de ces prochaines semaines et
joe biden va devoir redoubler
d'ingéniosité pour ne pas voir la
fracture s'agrandir encore entre ces
deux amériques qui ne se parlent plus